[Music]
in our morning rounds the science of
seasonal allergies medium high and
medium pollen counts are spread across
much of the country this morning you can
see them here highlighted in orange and
yellow around 26 million Americans find
themselves sneezing and wheezing every
year we spent 2.7 billion dollars last
year on non prescription allergy
remedies our dr. tara nurullah is with
us to explain the what the why the wind
how commiserate so who gets allergies
and who doesn't what's the sort of
deciding factor it is a complex
interplay between genetics your immune
system in the environment so we're
constantly scanning the environment for
threats and people who have allergic
disease they detect a threat in
something that the rest of us think is
harmless and they mount an attack they
sound the alarm
their body produces proteins or
antibodies that bind to cells and those
cells release chemical messengers like
histamine what does the histamine do it
causes a sneeze reflex to try to expel
the allergen it dilates the blood
vessels which causes congestion and it
also stimulates your glands which causes
mucus to form so all creating the misery
but in an attempt to kind of get rid of
what it thinks is an intruder is that an
evolutionary response so it is really
fascinating some evolutionary biologists
think that it is that it is a remnant a
holdover from a prior reaction to things
that were actually dangerous to our
ancestors like Venom's and toxins and
parasites in fact there are proteins on
parasites that resemble proteins to tree
allergens or pollen in addition the
immune reaction that we have to
allergies the antibodies we produce are
similar to the ones that we produce for
parasites what about the idea that their
people seem to be getting more allergies
than before is there any truth to the
hygiene hypothesis that we become too
clean
another very interesting discussion so
hygiene hypothesis was really started to
be discussed in 1989 when they saw that
kids who had older siblings seem to have
less allergic disease so it is this idea
that when you are in the womb your
immune system is not essentially present
your mother is providing antibodies when
you're born your immune system is weak
you need to train it educated build it
like you would strengthen muscles and
you do that by fighting off pathogens
that are real if you don't get that
experience it is possible that your
immune system becomes
directed dysregulated and so then you
basically attack things that are
resemble harmful things in terms of
pollen reach adulthood yes and you have
the symptoms what do you do well so you
should see an allergist you can get
tested take medication shots and tablets
that can help but also you can take
precautions like staying indoors during
five to ten a.m. washing your clothes
washed taking a shower to get the
allergens off washing your sheets
wearing sunglasses and a hat so that
lots of things you can do to prevent the
symptoms thank you thank you donating a
federal appeals court just ruled against
president Trump's temporary travel ban
ahead Homeland Security Secretary John
Kelly will join us here in studio 57
plus it's Baywatch time again this time
on the big screen let's see the runs
will break down the summers most
anticipated movies with rock yeah I know
I know this is what a girls favorites do
I think that yeah this is like smitten
crush what a good each other teacher
what about each other yeah future
husband material you're watching CBS
this morning
CBS morning rounds sponsored by
non-drowsy claritin and clara spray
products
[Music]